[Applause]
madonna shocks fans during her
appearance on the tonight show starring
jimmy fallon climbing on his desk and
flashing her backside to the audience
and it's gonna be a fun night on
thursday the 63 year old pop icon
stopped by the show to promote her
paramount plus concert documentary
madame x and she said she was inspired
by writer james baldwin who said artists
are here to disturb the peace and so i
hope that i have disturbed
not only your peace this afternoon but
you always disturb my pieces
watch the show but i mean that in the
best way no yeah you get in good trouble
well that's when madonna who was wearing
a black mini dress proceeded to lie
across jimmy's desk with no warning no
no no no no
stop stop stop stop stop
oh my heaven stop it stop it i don't
know what to do stop it right now
absolutely
and while jimmy legit seemed like he
didn't know what to do madonna seemed as
cool and calm as ever oh my god every
look at this
um
i i don't know what i don't know what
ever life is not just about interviewing
kitties
[Laughter]
e.t recently spoke with madonna at the
new york premiere of madame x where she
talked about what fans can expect from
the documentary which is now streaming
on paramount plus
great art
[Music]
thoughtfulness
incredible dancing incredible music
uh
gosh
provocation politics spirituality
family everything well your kids are in
it and your kids are in it my
boyfriend's in it everybody's in it
[Music]
you